salut bande de petits salopards
ici c'est le général du zaire je viens
vous parler parce que demain il y aura
peut-être la guerre alors bande de
trouillards de civils en cas de
bombardement
c'est pas la peine d'aller vous planquer
dans les stations de métro aucun et ruia
surtout si vous êtes à bordeaux n'y a
pas de métro elle est bonne alors été
l'armée pendant qu'un petit [ __ ]
attraper les bombes avant qu'elles
tombent par terre et rapporter les
douilles de campement elles sont
considérées comme en attaque c'est très
simple je vous montre avec ses mains
commencent à éclater dans de petits
salopards
si ça éclate c'est très simple bandeau
trouillard tu ramasses tes tripes tout à
l'air fou dans le buffet y est tu fais
un avec l'impro c'est compris les coûts
des lois si vous vous coupe les oreilles
et supplie combat de type e très bien
comme on attrape une bombe
c'est très simple se répète on compte
sur sa jambe arrière comme dans le coup
ce qu'on va et on tend les mains et on
regarde tomber la bombe trois ans les
yeux comme the saloperie de pigeons vous
m'avez ronco rue
quant aux petits salopards
[Musique]